supongamos que tengo el punto 3
menos 4 vamos a ubicar el punto sería 1
2 3 1 2 3 4 3 como menos 4 es el punto 3
coma menos 4 y supongamos que también
tenemos el punto 6 1 tenemos entonces 1
2 3 4 5 6 para x y uno para iu este es
el punto 6,1 en el último vídeo pudimos
establecer una fórmula para calcular
distancia entre dos puntos lo hicimos a
través del teorema de pitágoras trazamos
la línea que une los puntos y vimos que
es la hipotenusa de un triángulo
rectángulo en este vídeo vamos a
calcular las coordenadas del punto que
está precisamente la mitad entre estos
dos puntos si trazamos la línea que une
esos dos puntos que determina la
distancia entre esos dos puntos vamos a
encontrar las coordenadas del punto que
se encuentra precisamente a la mitad
vamos a determinar entonces las
coordenadas x y de ese punto medio
trazamos la gráfica por aquí en un
principio podría decir chispas esto va a
estar muy difícil tengo que usar la
fórmula distancia
puntos pero luego como le voy a hacer
pero no te vas a dar cuenta que es una
de las cosas más simples que puedes
aprender en álgebra y geometría digamos
entonces que este es mi triángulo este
que tenemos aquí es mi triángulo este
sería entonces el punto 61 este de aquí
sería el punto tres coma menos cuatro y
estamos buscando las coordenadas del
punto que está precisamente a la mitad
de este trayecto
cuáles son las coordenadas de ese punto
parece difícil en un principio pero es
muy simple cuando consideras por
separado las coordenadas xy de ese punto
entonces para las equis esta línea de
aquí representa x igual a 6 mientras que
esta de aquí deja de marcarla con un
color más oscuro esta línea representa x
igual a 6 esta línea representa x igual
a 3 entonces cuál sería la coordenada en
x del punto medio la coordenada en x del
punto medio va a estar precisamente a la
mitad entre 3 y 6 al dividir esta
distancia en 2 esta distancia de aquí es
igual a esta de acá la coordenada en x
va a estar justo a la mitad entre 3 y 6
y como llamamos a ese punto bueno
podemos llamarlo el punto medio o desde
otra perspectiva puedes llamarla como el
promedio o la media lo que queremos
encontrar el punto que marca la mitad
entre el trayecto de 3 a 6 y eso no lo
va a dar el promedio entre 3 y 6 así es
que para encontrar el punto medio entre
3 y 6 este punto de aquí vamos a sacar
el promedio de 3 y 6 esto es 3 + 6 entre
2 esto es igual a 4.5 así es que esta
coordenada en x va a ser 4.5 vamos a
ubicarlo en la gráfica entonces es 4.5
1-2-3-4 4.5 está justo a la mitad del
trayecto la coordenada en x es 4.5 ahora
por este mismo razonamiento la
coordenada njei del punto medio va a ser
la mitad entre ye igual a menos 4 y el
valor de y el valor de ye igual a 1 va a
estar justo la mitad vamos a calcularlo
este era la coordenada en x mientras que
la coordenada en que va a ser el
promedio entre menos 4 y 1 el promedio
entre menos 4 y 1 es 1
- 4 sobre 2 1 + menos 4 es igual a menos
3 sobre 2 o lo que es igual a menos 1.5
vamos a ubicarlo en la gráfica sería
menos 1.5 y ahí lo tenemos así de simple
tomamos el promedio de las x tomamos el
promedio de la 10 aunque deberíamos
decir la media para ser más precisos la
media entre dos valores ya hemos ubicado
el punto que se encuentra precisamente a
la mitad de estos dos puntos a partir
del cual la distancia hacia esos dos
puntos es igual el punto medio entre
estos dos puntos las coordenadas son
entonces 4.5 coma menos 1.5 vamos a un
par de problemas más te vas a dar cuenta
que a partir de lo que ya sabemos van a
ser sumamente fáciles vamos a graficar
los puntos para visualizarlos tenemos el
punto 4,5 1 1 2 3
4 - 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 - 5 este es el punto 4
menos 5 y el punto 8 2 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 2
aquí lo tenemos el punto 8,2 entonces
cuáles son las coordenadas del punto
medio entre esos dos puntos el punto que
se ubica justo a la mitad del tráiler
entre esos dos puntos calculemos las por
acá entonces va a ser el promedio de las
coordenadas en x que es 84 sobre 2 coma
el promedio de las coordenadas en y que
es 2 + menos 5 sobre 2 esto va a ser
igual 84 es 2 entre 12 6,2 más menos 5
es menos 3 entre 2 es menos tres medios
o menos 1.5 menos 1.5 y ahí lo tenemos
esas son las coordenadas del punto medio
el punto medio
básicamente sacamos el promedio las
equis sacamos el promedio las 10 vamos a
graficar el punto 6 menos 1.5 1 2 3 4 5
6 y menos 1.5 menos 1.5 y si se ve que
es el punto adecuado
la distancia entre estos dos puntos en
la misma que hay entre estos dos puntos
bien lo que hay que recordar es
promediar las coordenadas en x y tiene
la coordenada x del punto medio promedio
de las coordenadas serie y tiene la
coordenada njei del punto medio te voy a
mostrar ahora lo que aparece en los
libros de texto establecen que si
tenemos puntos
las x 1,1 y bueno lo iba a ser en rosa
pero no me quedo con amarillo para
hacerlo más simple y el otro punto de
coordenadas x 2,2
entonces para encontrar el punto medio
tengan una fórmula para calcular el
punto medio lo cual es absurdo memorizar
porque lo único que tienes que recordar
es que tienes calcular el promedio las
coordenadas en xy tome las coordenadas
en y entonces se establecen la fórmula
del punto medio la fórmula del punto
medio como la media de las coordenadas
en x aquí estoy inventando la anotación
luego con el mejor de la siguiente
manera la x media coma la media y esto
es igual a la x media es igual a x 1 x 2
sobre 2 coma la media que es de 1 más de
2 sobre 2 y parecería que es algo para
memorizar pero no fíjate bien este es el
promedio o la media entre estos dos
números y este número de acá la
coordenada en y es la media entre estos
dos números estoy haciendo la suma de
estos dos y viviendo la entre dos y
estoy haciendo la suma de estos dos y
dividiendo la entre 2
tengo el punto medio eso es todo lo que
tenemos que hacer